create content because your grandkids
are hoping you produce content so they
can study you when you're no longer here
with us if all of a sudden Elon Musk
invents this new technology to go back
to the future and have a drone follow
your grandparents for a hundred hours of
footage what's that word to you somebody
said Priceless by the way how many of
you guys get emotional just thinking
about it see that gets me emotional
because I've never met that man I'd love
to sit there as a 43 year old man who's
got four kids right now but when I watch
him I'll be a five-year-old grandson
watching my grandpa never met before
getting emotional over 100 hours to say
that's where I get that from oh my God
that's me that's where that comes from
that's sick one day your grandkids are
gonna hope there's content of you so for
some of you that are sitting there
saying why am I waiting to create
content the argument is over